with all due respect John F kin
president john f kennedy's branches
Caroline and Ted Kennedy is the united
states senator who has been the leader
of the Kennedy family and the Democratic
Party for more than 40 years and with
all due respect to john f kennedy's
other siblings i don't think anyone
believes that the lieutenant governor of
maryland has quite the same voice and
stature and national politics as the
united states senator since from
massachusetts since nineteen sixty-two
and the daughter of John F Kennedy
I believe that Ted Kennedy Caroline
Kennedy Patrick Kennedy all endorsed
Obama because the conduct of his
campaign was most like that of John F
Kennedy than that of any other candidate
because the ideals expressed by Obama
were most like the ideals of John F
Kennedy and by Ted Kennedy and his son
and niece so it was logical that they
would endorse Obama as the best kiln
they thought was the best candidate for
president but I should add that my book
most endorsements have very little
impact sometimes I have said to more
than one candidate the endorser you can
be sure you're going to get to his vote
and maybe his mother's if she's
registered but that's about it people
make up their own minds the endorsement
of the New York Times as has been proven
by all the candidates and they endorsed
over the years who lost including by the
way they endorsed opponents of Franklin
D Roosevelt 1940 and Harry Truman in
1948 who needs the New York Times to
tell them to vote against well-known
national figures so I think the New York
Times endorsement was not a disastrous
blow to obama i think the Kennedys are
different because obama has been so
identified by many people with the
spirit of John F Kennedy that it's
logical it's fitting it completes the
picture for the one kennedy in national
politics ed word and John f's own
daughter and Edwards son
in positive son in politics now that
makes a lot of sense i think i think
that the Kennedy family endorsement of
Obama will help but mostly endorsements
note i can tell you a true story evident
chicago introducing obama at an event
and afterwards member the press came up
to me and said in a very snippy way
would john f kennedy endorse Obama and I
said frankly I don't think there's much
power attached to the endorsement from
live politicians but I'm certainly not
going to speculate on an endorsement
from the dead